d'ailleurs bien vous si vous n'aviez pas
été comme ça voilà des des stars du
petit écran de la petite lucarne
qu'est ce que vous auriez fait dans la
vie gbagbo castadi on sait vous vous
auriez été à mon avis avocat pour
défendre des simples franchement vous
auriez fait quoi je pense qu'on était
peu preuve de plongée à prendre de
plongée c'est normal on parle pas c'est
oui papa chez jérôme marsac le fossé
mais la prochaine date infos que vous
avez fait de la plongée vous avez failli
mourir
non j'ai fait un plongeon oui bah oui
mes plongeons n'est pas la plongée sous
marine avec bouteille est simple on joue
pour plonger à givet un plongeur oui
bien sûr mais déjà que vous voyez rien
voir mais ça règle et vous voyez un
point seulement je vais aller pour une
baleine les gens ont un peu grandi quand
même non non c'est pas si simon
grandissent et votre mais j'attends
qu'ils ont grandi non mais alors vous
auriez fait quoi vous menez je serai
consacrer à l'écriture j'aurais été
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je sais
d'ici là elle est persuadée que c'est
marguerite duras rigoler mais oui mais
alors d'en tirer c'est que ça sera oui
ben si vous voulez gagner un petit bout
d'chou fait autre chose quand même
oui chasseur de trésor n'était pas
recherché n'était pas avec des bateaux
des oui non c'est pas mal ça chasse
endroit vers moi aussi j'ai toujours
rêvé de recherche un trader à chaque
fois je vais chez un ami je tape comme
ça sur les murs voir s'il muret creux
comme ça et des fois je prends une masse
et je vais là j'ai pété le mur du salon
la patrie des dragons seclinois pas mal
de bouquets ligne moi j'aurais voulu
être chanteuse chanteuse ça doit à
chaque fois pendant les pubs elle chante
et elle entend que j'ai pas chanter
d'ailleurs oui mais non vous n'y avez
pas d s'il aurait fallu mannequin moi
aussi chanteur mais chanteur d'opéra et
tournoyant une paillasse
gênant c'est mozart
les frères métatarse c'est quoi ça et
chant fin aux iphone tout est connecté
cosi fan tutte voilà pizza toute l'année
il faut deux jours les métiers de motta
c2 qui au cosi fan tutte d'armoise à
mozart mozart pour ça le salaire grand
le numérique zarbo mais non c'est pas
mozart ça va notre vie que c'est
beethoven karemera mais confond mozart
avec un chien mais très calme et voilà
la sheo et tu t'es pris ta mère merci
non mais malheureusement j'ai pas la
voie pour j'ai pas le cas lorsque vous
connaissez pas alors ils disent à ce que
c'est une paillasse oui non même s'il y
avait quoi ils parlent pas français et
qui dirait c'est une paillasse seuil en
italien mais si c'est tout bas la stasi
pareil en anglais on sait en italien une
paillasse et une paillasse vous emmerder
par fait visiter son appartement y met
trimestre ou d'un métro d'autres pays
à part de travers non c'est pas ça qui
partent de travers c'est la venue de
poser la question au coeur parce que
j'ai 90 à vous faire d'ailleurs ah oui
vous allez paris non non j'aurais été
acteur mes actes la troisième vie et il
est un peu et du coup dans un an max
j'arrête la télévision pour me consacrer
totalement à ce métier que sa réponse
est non je pense bon ça veut dire qu'ils
arrêtent un nom il va faire une semaine
de casting compétentes encore une saison
avec vous après gmail vous croyez en moi
fait plaisir après j'arrête tout je me
consacre à cette nouvelle vie et ben
bravo je peux vous dire pourquoi il fait
ça pourquoi ça parce qu'il ya une
fouille avec fabien otteniente qui était
invité mais le réaliser a été battue
était là il c'est vrai qu'il est tel
jour là était assez brillants ils
étaient brûlés souvent bouissou a
raisonné et pendant une coupure pub
fabien été voir mathieu en lisant je te
trouve très bon j'aimerais que tu sois
pas besoin de mai prochain film c'est
qu'il ne parle de lui toute espèce
maison fabien match voiture est alors
alors alors avait livré du pouvoir il
est venu me voir les vidéos à mon
associé pour qu'on produit son prochain
film
mais non et ouais et nous à nice avec
qui mathieu de rioux je lis je vais pas
un euro là dessus
alors vous styliste je pense
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
aux délais de la pub pour les jus
d'orange karimouche j'adore c'est
magnifique
vient alors oui eh ben moi me laisser
vivre
allez voir des procès d'assises pour
écrire des polars et faire chier les
promoteurs qui bétonnent tout et sinon
un truc un métier c'est à dire sinon
vous auriez fait quoi vous je me suis
mariée c'est déjà un métier en équipe
pour qu'il gagne ma vie donc moi je suis
sûr au moins quelqu'un qui brille
géraldine c'est bon là c'est bon là on a
récupéré tous les téléspectateurs à moi
direct architecte d'intérieur nom arrive
chez vous java les murs je mets des
baignoires
ah ouais ouais c'est pas des baignoires
bâchées bars america n'a pas voulu me
c'est bien non les bénéficiaires pour
les enfants elle c'est le genre de bafa
table tu t'assois pas sur un tabouret de
tableau
est ce qu'on mange chaire histoire gigot
d'agneau dans la baignoire mais a lancé
à votre espace quoi votre espace vital
non parce que vous vous pourriez être
potentiellement un client oui non oui le
sas vous adorez les baignoires sont avec
vous dit quoi avec tout le liquide que
vous verrez
c'a donné deux semaines d'isabelle
harraga taupont bien professeurs des
écoles ou professeurs de français comme
un moment ah ouais professeur de
français les séries alors est ce que
vous vous détectez des fautes de
français autour de la table est ce que
votre maman trouve qu'on parle bien
français santé pmp s'est étonnamment
satisfaisant
ah oui il y en a eu beaucoup et comment
il a dit décollement jeter ou père n'a
fait une chaleur le miroir
il a dit en vélo et on dit d'accord et
harek l'andouille ça va mieux mais
arrête l'andouille avec un grand e alors
ah bah alors là la petite qu'est ce que
vous auriez fait ou si vous n'aviez pas
rien fait
[Rires]
c'est sûr on avait une carrière dans
peut-être l'administration française
peut-être voilà alors l'administration
française et sont ouverts de 16h à 19h
vous trois heures on arrive en échange
de tirs a pas non vous auriez fait quoi
je retravaillais ou aux ptt
ça existe encore une grande écoute doc
gynéco l'apostillé bonjour bonjour
bonjour je vais à chercher inconnues
inconnues
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
z oo
oui je viens chercher un colis on va on
va certainement livré quelque chose de
ces de ma famille ou juste malam boukar
manèges jeux et loi evin qui le verra la
poste wah wah wah 17h tu as fini
[Rires]
bravo bravo jean échos